let's talk about this the spying bill so
as many of you may be aware there's been
a lot of a lot of news lately about
australia there have been protests over
the lockdowns the lockdowns are the most
draconian thing we've ever seen
meanwhile you know like chris hemsworth
is surfing on the beach and he's having
a smile on his face and even even though
the beach is under a strict lockdown
you're not allowed to leave your house
but the rich people seem to be okay but
everybody else is kind of complaining as
to why they're locked down people are
protesting hundreds of people are
getting arrested
and now we have this on top of it
australian powers to spy on cyber crime
suspects given green light i love how
they say cyber crime suspects coalition
bill to create powerful new warrants
allowing authorities to modify and
delete data and even take over accounts
passes the senate that is
amazing they say the identify and
disrupt bill pass the senate on
wednesday despite concerns about the low
bar of who can authorize a warrant and
the government failed to implement all
the safeguards recommended by the
bipartisan joint committee on
intelligence and security and apparently
it was like just like sped through
parliament or whatever is that how it
works you guys have parliament yeah and
then they just like rubber stamped it so
imagine this
you are talking to your friends about
hey you know like i think this lockdown
stuff's pretty bad and then all of a
sudden you get a knock on the door and
they're like we have copied all of your
phone's photos and video and everything
we own it and uh we found ourselves a
crime
because come on there's like i'm sure
it's similar in australia like it is
here there's just so many laws in the
books you're always breaking crime
you're always breaking laws isn't there
a book about this yeah we we had someone
talk about like yeah like four crimes a
day or something yeah four crimes a day
people are committing yeah and not only
that
but if they have access to your phones
your communications and all that stuff
there could be a joke
and they'll be like nope that's serious
you could jokingly say something like oh
you know i would do x y or z
you know and they'll there was like one
story we saw of a guy who was posting
memes or something and a discord server
and then the cops came and arrested him
because it was public so anyway let's
just talk about you know australia is a
country of monsters and dragons and
mythical beasts that always want to kill
you
most of the country is a barren
wasteland of death yes you know also
true and there was a story about a woman
who whose apple maps told her to take a
wrong turn and then she drove like 500
miles into the outback and then like car
broke down and she was stranded because
just like the country is it's like a
death pit full of monsters and the sa
the places that were safe the cities
have now been overrun by like full-on
fascism that they're going to arrest you
lock you in your home there's a video of
like a a woman walking on the street and
the cop starts beating her because she
wasn't wearing a mask even though she
had a medical exemption yeah he dragged
her to the ground they dragged her to
the ground yeah that's it so let me
let's just start by asking i'll ask you
cindy what the hell is wrong with you
people
you know i've been asking that about her
for a long time
um honestly it's funny because people
always ask me why did you leave
australia and this is sort of why like
on an un-ironic note and i don't want to
[ __ ] on australians too much sorry i've
already i've already ruined your thing
i'm sorry all right
i don't want to i don't want to um rag
on australians too much because i do
love aussies but dead set i got to a
point where i was like this is a bloody
prison this is actually a prison and i
want it it's always been i know but i
didn't realize it until i was like oh
god i'm like the only well i feel like
i'm the only person living in the you
know communist republic of victoria that
actually gives a damn about freedom and
doesn't want to uh live in you know
abject uh government overrun
horribleness for the rest of my days so
i was like let's go to america texas i
know that was like
you know you were begging for freedom
you know i was yeah i want to turn it
through that's single too by the way
she's still not married
i'm trying i'm trying so hard i'm just
saying she's not married
any guy that wants to show her a life of
she has the dream of living on a ranch i
do with horses i want some cows oh god
cows are so cute
they'll cuddle you yeah they'll put your
finger in their mouth and they'll like
suck on it
apparently it feels good i've never done
it why that someone told me that
i got it i'm a vessel of knowledge
in conversation i like cows too
basically that's what i'm saying but
yeah
is it just fingers is it just fingers
okay all right all right i know it's
just asking but no but you know it's
funny because you know i guess they
don't know that's my wife but kev
actually said the same thing and people
like how did she just leave
australia
wow that's gonna start calling instead
of the like the storks brought brought
the baby i was like you know how our
babies made you stick your finger in the
cow's mouth and then it all
sucks on your finger
you're on the internet too much
everything i said was true like lively
because there's too much over there no
and she was like people go why was she
willing to move over here so quickly
because a lot of people are in two camps
in australia that people don't
understand i would say the majority of
people are very subservient that they
trust the government that they think the
government is on their side if you deny
and you fight against the government to
put into perspective we did a podcast
together and some people that i know
over there were saying that we sounded
communist because we were questioning
the government and we are very far away
from communists go to vash or something
if you want to watch communism don't go
to slightly offensive or sydney watson
our shows but the point is is that
there's this camp of people i would say
it's about one-third or less that are
just like we are so sincerely effed and
i'm going to probably need to get out of
here and i don't know how we meet
australians all around america they've
got the green card lottery that wanted
to get out because people are so cucked
out and subjugated to this crown and to
the authority they can't think for
themselves and they look at the people
who are against the government as being
like bad behaved citizens yeah like
they're they're bad people morally there
was a there was a manhunt for a guy
because he was coughing in the elevator
well because he had covered because he
because he left locked down because well
but he apparently he was told so this
guy he was told to go quarantine at a
hotel
and so there's video of him leaving his
apartment and they're like look at him
in the in the elevator sneezing
like what that's a weird thing but
apparently they found him in a hotel
quarantining right and they're like
you're under arrest mate and then they
drag him out and people are cheering
didn't he get like eight months in
prison or something like that no no no
that was that was the protester
well perhaps i'm wrong someone should
double check me on this but i think they
might have um arrested him and done like
i'm pretty sure they arrested him like
he's a terrorist they put him in like in
garbs and masks and gloves and carried
like drag physically dragged him out
none of this is new i i can't stress
this enough to americans none of this is
new it's not like this is something that
someone just pulled from the sky you
know the politicians suddenly were like
oh you know what let's become draconian
no this is this is honestly part of my
frustration with australia it always
always has been this is why i left
because australians in a lot of ways and
i think i've said this probably on this
show before and i know i've certainly
said on your show but aussies in a lot
of ways i'm not saying all aussies but a
portion of them view security as much
more important than freedom so when you
have that as the primary mentality and
the primary prevailing attitude of most
of your population or at least a large
portion of the population then of course
what we're seeing at the moment is a
byproduct of that and people just roll
over because they go oh you know if we
follow the law daddy government will
give me my rights back
honey when was the last time the
government did anything for you i think
it was dave smith who said there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
government program seriously honestly
like maybe maybe he was quoting i forget
who was but he was quoting he said that
on this show uh anthony karim has not
been sentenced he was just charged but
he was denied bail and he's been charged
with 13 offenses they called him public
health enemy number one that's
ridiculous allegedly went on the run
i love how in the news report they've
got like five cops and they're like
we're like in swat gear and they've got
a bunch of doctors in full like pandemic
panic garb and then they're like he was
you know he was refusing quarantine
though he was found in the hotel where
the authorities had told him he should
quarantine and i'm like
the crazy thing about the story is for
all i know they got video of the guy
leaving his house to go to the hotel
like he was told and then they were like
oh but why is he why is he sneezing in
public arrest him did you guys watch the
i'm sure some of you saw enemy number
one yeah it's got to be merch
australians are so hyperbolic like that
like i don't know if you guys saw there
was a news report about him and the
there's like you were talking about the
australian commentator was like this is
whatever his name is adam steps into the
it was also dramatic and i'm going the
dude has the sniffles what is what are
we what is happening right now well to
be fair
sneezing and coughing without covering
your mouth in an elevator kind of a dick
move yeah not not worthy of a man
hunting was anybody else in the elevator
with him no but still come on yeah
increasingly i was spitting on the
window i don't know sneezing
but i will say this go to any major
metropolitan area in the united states
and it's quite a similar experience in
fact i think you just fit in but in
australia people are very prim they are
very proper in a lot of the major cities
it's very clean compared to u.s cities
are very clean they're very orderly yes
and what i want to point out that people
don't know is that australians are also
like super based with their immigration
policies and have actually take
everything very seriously they could be
a threat to their culture to their
ethnic uh their mono culture to any of
these things they see these as huge
threats so it makes sense that you could
also take another enemy that could
threaten you and they have that island
mentality where it's like we can keep
covet away completely because we're on
an island and so they've taken it to an
extremity to where people thought and i
think this is crazy but they thought
that they could essentially remain
isolated from the world and never have a
cove of death in their country ever as
if respiratory illness what new zealand
did too yeah would never ever find their
way in you know what's funny i posted i
posted on twitter something to the
effective you know i didn't really ever
expect to be at a point where we would
have these quarantine camps and yet here
we are and someone responded and i have
to give them props for this they
responded and said sydney you literally
take your asylum seekers and send them
to an offshore processing detention
center and i thought to myself yeah one
that i've actually defended in the past
so i'm in australia yeah yeah so what we
do is because we call them boat people
just you know based yeah that's awesome
and the boat and the boat people come to
the borders and obviously the australian
police or whoever deals with it you know
border protection goes
nope and sends them to christmas island
conveniently named christmas island and
not so has nothing to do with christmas
um and there they stay
maybe indefinitely i'm not sure so
putting putting your own cities back a
lot of times they ship them back but i
mean it does take a long time and these
people obviously burn down the
facilities and and break things and you
know molest and raise the signs on the
beaches are like if you see their their
immigration signs it's something out of
like what would be considered here
extreme right wing which is basically
just means being epic um where it it
basically just has like a warship like
almost like tipping a boat of people and
it's like don't come here don't come
here you're gonna get tipped like that's
basically what it says it's weird it's
so extreme like you might die if you try
to come here we have a deal with um
papua new guinea and it's basically like
hey we'll send you all the asylum
seekers we just don't want to deal with
them but i guess the thing is right
those are not citizens of australia yeah
here take them take them these are not
citizens though so i mean it sounds
heartless and i don't want to get into
the immigration debate necessarily but
it sounds heartless to just be like yeah
okay but you're you can't do this crap
to your own citizens these are people
that live work you know contribute to
your economy pay taxes thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time